soleil et bonne humeur à l'ouverture de
cette journée dédiée au commerce de
proximité
depuis plusieurs années maurepas 19
mille habitants déplorent la fermeture
de ces petites enseignes en cause des
affaires qui se porte mal ou des
boutiques qui ne trouve pas preneur
la libraire a disparu il faut remettre
une librairie parce que sinon il ya plus
libre art il faut aller à trappes wawa
l'encours chercher son journal
les gens n'avaient pu bouger maintenant
ils préfèrent prendre leurs boîtes
d'allumettes l'un avec les drives même
mec même les grandes surfaces ont touché
à ce niveau là là c'est foutu pour le
commerce un résultat le centre ville
perd de son dynamisme en 2014 le taux de
vacance commercial atteignait 15% en
ile-de-france un déclin qui touche
particulièrement les communes de moins
de cent mille habitants celle ci ne
bénéficie pas de l'attractivité
touristique des métropoles alors la
résistance des riverains se met en place
c'est à nous en tant qu riverains de
favoriser quand on peut le petit
commerce plutôt que d'aller
systématiquement aller dans les grands
en scène car au delà de la qualité du
produit c'est une expérience de
consommation chaleureuse que les
habitants recher che avec le commerce de
proximité
nous sommes proches de nos clients avant
tout et donc on essaye de de continuer
ainsi nous ce qui compte c'est la
fidélité
depuis
38 ans pratiquement que nous sommes ici
d'abord pas
voilà ce qui fait que nous existons
encore et on espère encore très
longtemps ici les élus se battent pour
freiner la fermeture des petits
commerces malgré une marge de manoeuvre
réduite
je reçois des messages de mort patients
qui me disent qu'ils sont évidemment
attaché alors leur commerce local
d'autant plus que quand vous avez des
cellules qui sont vides où vous avez des
commerces qui s'en vont les morlaisiens
s'adresse directement aux maires alors
que j'ai pas forcément la main dans le
sens où ce sont des activités privées et
donc le rôle d'une municipalité c'est
d'accompagner des c2 de renouveler en
tout cas les activités de faire en sorte
de savoir qui est propriétaire des murs
qui est propriétaire des fonds qui est
propriétaire des baux pour accompagner à
l'échelle régionale les collectivités
locales investissent elles aussi dans le
maintien du commerce de proximité le
futur réseau de transport grand paris
express doit desservir en priorité les
centres villes